all right so never missing an
opportunity to play identity Politics
the left continues to blame racism for
former Harvard president claudian Gay's
resignation earlier today the Reverend
Al Sharpton LED his group The National
Action Network in a protest outside of
billionaire Harvard alumni Alum Bill
amman's office to show quote that his
attacks on Dei president gay and black
Americans have consequences Amman well
he responded on X the platform for known
as Twitter offering to meet with the
Reverend Al Sharpton regarding his
concern anyway there's only one person I
wanted for reaction to all of this and
that's Louisiana Senator John Kennedy
Senator you've seen the exchange with
these three presidents of these three
big colleges and Elise stefanic we we've
all seen the tape their answers were
appalling shocking and frankly repulsive
um I don't know why it took also charges
of plagiar ISM for Claud and Gade to go
but I just want your
reaction uh Dr Gay of course has
resigned uh she should have I uh I I I
bear her no ill
will um my advice to her for what it's
worth is that when one door closes
sometimes you need to uh get a hammer in
some nails and make make sure that will
be stay shut because Dr Gay had no
business running a
university the the plagiarism
allegations against her serious I think
most Americans found repugnant her
suggestion Express or implied that um it
might be okay to kill Jewish people in
the proper
context my biggest quarrel with Dr Gay
is that she does not understand the
purpose of a university the purpose of
the university is to make young people
think not to make them comfortable the
discussion of ideas should not be closed
off there's not only there's not only
one point of view if if you want to
believe that math is racist and Merit is
privilege uh or that men can breastfeed
this is America you're entitled to
believe that but other students who
disagree should feel free to disagree
and the truth is that every advancement
every single one in art science
philosophy uh technology cooking golf
came when someone challenged the rules
challenged dogma and uh and said there's
a better way and that's what our
universi should encourage instead of
just one point of view which I think Dr
Gay was guilty of
well we all know how conservatives are
treated on college campuses around the
country diversity equity and inclusion
Dei as they call it what is your
reaction to
that well let me let me answer by
responding to Reverend Sharpton i' I've
uh I've read his comments and he of
course is entitled to to his opinion his
mine America is not perfect but we are
good uh like every other
civilization uh America caught the
disease of slavery but we beat it back
and we're proud of that and since then
we passed civil rights laws in
1875 1960 1964 1968
1991 uh we made a lot of racial progress
in this country and I think we've
reached the point where most not all but
most Americans don't think about that
much about race they think about
character they understand as I've said
before that to a bear we all taste like
chicken now I don't believe race should
be used to harm a person or to help a
person and I think most Americans
believe that I I don't think Reverend
Sharpton would agree with me I think he
believes that to disregard race is
racist and that to me is a is a uncons
tional and and morally wrong but he's
entitled his point of view how is it
that Joe Biden um seems to have gotten
away with and this happened in the
leadup to the 2020 campaign and that is
that he partnered with a former K Klux
Clansman by the name of Robert bird and
fought against the integration of public
schools it was his words not mine that
he didn't want public schools to become
racial jungles how is it that a
Democratic party you know they would
they would go after any conservative
that held that position and fought for
that position how come Joe Biden got a
pass well I think uh I think most
members of the media not all but most
members of the media have tried to help
President Biden as as uh as much as they
can I I know with many members of the
media in my state that's been the case
but but as I said the other day um the
American people are not
stupid uh but they think that Joe Biden
is and there's a lot of evidence for
that he's running out of toes to shoot
off uh the border is uh is exhibit a and
uh as as I've also said on your show
before the American people they're busy
they don't have time to read Socrates
every day they're busy earning a living
but sooner or later they figure it out
and they have figured it out uh with
respect to president Biden his uh his
friends in the media not withstanding uh
and I think he's going to have a rough
election
cycle all right I think it's going to be
a roller coaster of a year probably
unprecedented unlike any we've seen in
our lifetime that is maybe the one
certainty we can we can talk about at
this point uh Senator Kennedy happy New
Year great to see you thanks for being
back with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else